marlins will hand the ball to zach
thompson his ninth start this season
and in his career coming off a loss
against the yankees and a
208 era in this ballpark where he
certainly seems comfortable as well and
he'll face the mets
for the first time in his career brandon
nimmo set to dig in thompson ready for
another
2-2 pitch and a ground ball that's issan
diaz from the outfield grass and finally
he puts away brandon nimmo for the first
out
in steps jeff mcneal
this one's in the air back behind short
and
jazz ranging back to make the play two
down and now pete alonso with nobody on
and two out
three two down poked out to left field
alfaro
makes the play out there and zach
thompson retires the mets in order
here in the first carlos carrasco's
toyota numbers gave up that
leadoff home run from the first pitch to
jonathan india
after that was pretty spotless 88 and 73
in his career with 196 starts
chisholm two for four in the opening
game of the series monday before he was
way laid on the covet list yesterday
here's the two-seamer grounded on the
right side baez playing in the shift
throws out chisholm for the first down
issan diaz having a good series three
for seven with a double on a home run
pops up fastball into left field and dom
smith is there waiting for it
and that's the second out so carrasco
has retired the first two
here's jesus aguilar one for five in
this series
and he pops it up into shallow center
out goes mcneal calling and mcneil puts
it away with two hands to retire the
side carrasco gets the marlins one two
three no score after one now the mets on
the base is loaded with nobody out
here's vr
the former marlin and that's
topped past the mound diaz will have to
play it to first underhand
just in time to get vr as a run comes
home so it's a triply productive out for
vr he gets to run in
and advances the other two runners the
mets have a one-nothing lead
just too slowly for diaz to make any
other play he almost lost that play with
that weak underhand flip
well good change up here by the pitcher
gets by him and you're right diaz needs
to toss that ball and not underhand it
with the speed of vr so now florida
native tomas nito will come up
second and third and one out and nito
hammers one on the ground aguilar coming
home with it for the tag play and bias
is safe
looked like it got there in time with
the home plate on fire angel hernandez
said baez got in around the tag by
jackson to make it two nothing new york
and we'll see if the marlins challenge
wow maybe some trickery with that slide
by baez
give him the old okie doke yeah a little
okie doke to maybe get that hand in
before jackson could apply
the tag it'll be a fielder's choice
and here's the play at the plate jackson
had it in plenty of time
baez took the left hand away and got the
right hand in wow you know we talk about
baez and his instincts for the game and
how you have to keep your eye on him
that's one of the things
that he can do and because jackson
didn't get over there he allowed by us
to
have that trickery so it's two nothing
new york and now carrasco bats
with first and third and one out
carrasco one career run better than gets
the bunt down but it's too hard
top to the second a bad throw and
conformer will come in with the third
runner
it was not a good bunt by carrasco
thompson made the right choice throwing
to second
but he made a terrible throw and on the
air
the mets now have a three-nothing lead
well got to be an athlete when you're on
that mound also
had an opportunity to not only get the
out of second
but carrasco is not running hard because
of that hamstring
that was a chance for a double play if
he makes the proper throw but just
spiked it
into the ground bets lead three nothing
over the marlins bottom of the second
lewis brinson will lead off
and a good slider to strike out brinson
that's his first strike out of the night
and carrasco set down the first four
so he can wipe hitters out especially
with the slider one out nobody on brian
anderson the batter
lift it out to right center and conforto
and nimmo come together and
nemo gives way and forto makes the catch
two out
two up two down five in a row set down
by carrasco to start the game
better now jorge alfaro carrasco's got
it working tonight he strikes out el
faro on three pitches six
up and six down for carlos carrasco he's
got a three nothing lead after two
home third inning carlos carrasco's
retired the first six marlins
he gets brian de la cruz to start the
third
and that's lined toward the middle one
hopper grabbed by mcneil the quick
throw on a hop and alonso digs it out
beautifully done on both ends against
the speed of de la cruz mcneil got rid
of it as fast as he could
and pete did the rest with the scoop two
balls two strikes on joe panicked
hundreds on
first and second one out the marlins
down by three panic into center field
that's the base hit how far is going to
get the green light
bro goes to third it's cut off rbi
pinch it single for joe panic and the
marlins trail this swim three to one
joe putting together a quality pitch hit
at bat
bought off a couple of tough pitches in
and his arms extended
carrasco missed the mark 88 miles an
hour outer third that ball was supposed
to be
in panic all over it that's going to do
it for carrasco as luis rojas comes out
to take the ball from him
aaron lupa is coming into this ball game
jazz chisholm is coming to bat
payoff pitch coming to jazz and a ground
ball
to short baez has it goes to second
mcneil can't turn the double play
a run will score and the marlins get a
little bit closer now three to two
rogue to get it going if you're in a
good hitter's count you got to be
looking down the middle and give it a
ride
and aguilar hit a ton down the line
this is gone game tying home run
now that is how you tie up a baseball
game in the
sixth you take a hanging slider
and you hit a no doubter to the left
in the eighth against anthony bass and
javi lifts one down the right field line
slicing toward the corner that ball is
out of here
javi baez goes the other way an
opposite field home run for baez his
second has amit
his 24th of the year and baez puts the
mets in front of the top of the eighth
it's
to three new york opposite field power
for javi baez
not even that bad of a pitch by bass but
he has so much plate coverage
and so much talent to be able to take a
picture off the strike zone
and down and hit it over the right field
wall byers
chirping at the bench of the marlin
boy he's got a he's got a little wild
side to him
yeah wow yeah he does wanted to get he
wanted that buyer know to keep talking
about what
him pointing at the marlins dug out on
his way to the plate this goes back to
last night when he was
doing that chirping sign to richard
blyer after bleyer got him out
and four to a third dave is set to run
again from first
and nemo takes ball four here comes the
runner from
third conforto scores and it's five to
three new york
a wild pitch on ball four and conforto
scoots home sean guther making his major
league debut
seventh round pick of the marlins back
in 2017 out of the university of
notre dame imperative that they keep
this at a two run deficit
payoff pitch to vr is in there for a
called strike three
first big league strikeout for sean
gunther oh perfect timing for gunther
able to dial up the inside corner vr
gives up
on this 94 mile an hour fastball the
door is open to get out of this
here's tomas nedo 3-2 pitch swing
and a miss strike three and sean gunther
wraps up
his first inning in the major leagues
with a couple of punch-outs and he
strands a couple of runners
now the marlins are down to their final
out again the 3-2 from may to de la cruz
he struck him out and the ball game is
open trevor may with a one two three
ninth strikes out of pair
he fills in for diaz and picks up his
fourth save
and the mets with a much needed win as
they snap a three-game losing streak and
beat the marlins tonight
5-3